[Música]
bom dia boa tarde boa noite
é um filme com uma placa de rua então se
inscreve no canal pega esse vídeo manda
paulo amigos eu pego ele se inscrever no
canal rumo e chega logo não havendo mais
o calor me deixa puto edel bukit não
esquece clicar em gostei cara porque é
muito importante para o youtube entender
que sequer recebemos vi muita gente fica
muito sendo proposta no vídeo já postei
três vídeo a pessoa não sabe por que ela
assista o vídeo esquece de que gostei eo
youtube para de mandar pra você então
clica logo gostei agora já estávamos há
um vídeo muito mais meu amigo de kaloré
e eu não sei o que está acontecendo com
a camada de antônio eu tô doente é um
lado respiro tá mas sinto pico depois
que como banana verde tomando muito
hábito gripada e aliado esse calor do
cão aqui também toda vez que pego com
alguém é podre pato doente a pessoa faz
é beber muita água chegou a virar um
caminhão pipa que mais sabe que o cabelo
eu vou fazer igual àquele maratonista
não e as piadas que eu tenho que
aguentar ainda o calor do cão aqui em
são paulo eu estou com sede à pessoa
corpo da outra não está com sede em
importar acostumado com isso é do piauí
curta outra digo sim meu filho só do
piauí eu não sou o camelo meu cabelo
gosta mesmo de calor que não fala do
tipo cabelo começar a falar a primeira
frase que ele faz na europa eu nasci no
calo sim eu tenho costume
frio não 22 raul já tô redor de uma
fogueira ação lamachi mel sim mas não
quer dizer que eu vá ficar lotada no
calor ninguém fica de boca carta mora em
são paulo em dois anos já é a primeira
vez que eu sinto o calor do carai
destaque é a única que o rabino valor
que tudo que o cara falar no calor com
rabos a atenção para a fala assim eu vou
tomar um sorvete ora essa desgraça vai
tocar um piano
[Música]
ah
a pasta ganhou na mega-sena a ser via
deixar que em casa tudo lembra uma [__]
lotérica não só décima pole e só pede
informação pra você na rua se você tiver
no frio muita coisa é você sabe onde
fica a rua das oliveiras
sim claro claro claro meu caro amigo
quatro claro ficaria honrado em
acompanhar foi infelizmente terei que
buscar os filhos nas escolas né das
felizmente não felizmente não é feliz
feliz é aquele de crianças que têm filho
no calor da ok ok pode saber onde a
rússia no dia você sabe dizer onde é que
a roda não o liberou para a morte não
cheguei agora chega agora que me conheço
há 20 anos ele morando no freio ao
menino pedindo um negócio na mãe comprou
um sorvete pra mim lá que co
mas só depois que você começou a saúde
dos consumidores
bom aí decidiram trabalho avisa kaká
soube que você que é esse o korando onde
vou colar jardim assunto não encontrou
comprador os dois no calor é não somente
é capaz dessa baixa na quinta dirigente
já tô maluco acho que filho no calor não
é bom acho que nunca é bom ter sobre
entendeu que deve ser brincar um
pouquinho começou a ficar preta aqui no
pescoço já traga de volta o gosto do
nordeste no reclamando de calor porque
quando o nordeste vai reclamar e kalou é
porque tá aqui que eu jogue como ela é
de são paulo que só sai do sol pra carai
consta no mapa do mundo regata pode
pagar é com raiva mesmo é que dilma já
agora também faz frio e 1988 no primeiro
dia que eu cheguei só faltava tão frio
tão frio e eu fui dar um dia falei nery
gol acredita agora quer achar um lugar
mais quente do que você está achando que
tinha entrado em um carro estacionado no
sol que marie meio e abre a porta do
carro parece estar entrando em teresina
passa meia hora fazendo assim a rolar eu
tenho e não parei pra ele agora dá pra
ir liga o carro carro faz
a língua condicionado a fonte da cnb com
rádios tocando lady gaga aguento mais
cana do santana
mas eu quero saber de você tá calor tá
frio onde você mora e o que você mais
gosta de frio e de calor começa aqui em
baixo não esquece de clicar com gostei
tá isso é muito importante e clique em
gostei
o youtube entende que você quer receber
meus vídeos entendeu não se esquece se
inscrever no canal que a gente arruma 50
milhões para pegar a placa derrube do
youtube então se inscreve
manda esse vídeo com alguns amigos seus
e pede para se inscrever no canal vamos
chegar logo em e aí flu valeu em pé e
política